[Musique]
total
le groupe ajoutant qu ils débarquent
bien pour à valence en poitou pour les
armes à gabon est justement facilement
se trouve le bûcher de l'attraper on y
va
[Musique]
un
jeu
de production de miel à commence
on va dire réellement à partir de mois
de d'avril avec la première mêlée qu'il
a mis les deux printemps donc c'était un
tout fleurs mélangez avec tous les
arbustes et fleurs de printemps jusqu'à
peu près au 1er mai environ
on enchaîne après par la miel d'acacia
non contre enzymes nos ruches c'est à
dire qu on les déplace
ensuite après l'acacia vient de
châtaignier qu'en ce moment on doit
commencer la récolte c'est l'après midi
et là on commence à les placer une ruche
pour la miellée d'été donc de tournesol
en soit c'est derrière on aura encore de
petit mil et de sarrasin et de flore de
cours on va dire qu'on fait avec
quasiment une récolte tous les mois à
partir du 1er mai
sur les floraisons s'enchaînent donc on
déplace le rush ans sur des gros pôles
de floraison donc pour la casse hier en
déplacement viennent tous qu'il ya des
grandes forêts d'acacias après le
châtaignier chez nous beaucoup de
châtaigniers et ensuite le pour le
tournesol ça dépend du type de sol en
réalité il ya les terres lourdes donne
beaucoup moins en miel que l'était un
peu profond très gros du travail
commence à peu près quand les
consommables tout ce qu'on appelle poser
les oufs donc c'est à dire quand les
russes commencent à être productif c'est
à dire au début avril on passe chaque
semaine sur chaque ruche jusqu'au 10
juin à peu près et ensuite il ya toute
la période de transhumance donc tous les
tous les mois aussi tous les débuts de
mois qui est assez lourde et on va dire
que la grosse planète se finit après les
les mise en hivernage et des traitements
après le match à lens on a vraiment six
mois très très intenses et quand je dis
intense c'est
au fond pas les heures par contre après
l'hiver on est plus tranquille année on
a eu un gros coup de chaud sur les
châtaigniers par exemple on n'avait pas
eu d'eau avant du tout du tout du tout
dans notre région ça a été un peu
catastrophique quoi chatouiller les
coûts toujours plus de 40 les des fleurs
c'est comme nous
ça tout fait avorter en eau donc on a
une mine et de châtaigniers qui veut à
la hauteur de ce qu'on espérait les
ruches étaient prêtes il y avait tout
pour mais le temps a pas fait évolué sur
un cheptel d'à peu près mille cent mille
deux cents colonies
550 colonies destinés à la production de
miel et puis tout le reste pour
l'élevage et la bande dessin que mon
produit énormément de de rennes
pour multiplier dans mon cheptel et puis
on revend tout ça c'est des apiculteurs
amateurs ou professionnels c'est après
tout la partie production de miel est
vendu en direct donc on dirait que
j'entends un intermédiaire maximum donc
tout et
tout est vendu soit en magasin ou soit
directement au marché
on fonctionne avec les grandes surfaces
des magasins de producteurs et on
adhérents du réseau bienvenue à la ferme
et damart poteau qui nous permettent
d'avoir des réseaux de vente aussi un
peu plus diversifiée quand vous allez
pouvoir compter dans le maine d'acacia
donc très vite il très sucré
qui restent en embuscade même en effet
sucre venez goûter les différents miel
du rucher de la sape et acacias
châtaigniers bruyère il y en a pour tous
les goûts alors passer par perry